Before you see a single image in the Lord of the Rings trilogy,
you hear a choir singing in a little worrying harmonic minor key on a black background.
This is the music theme that is related to the Lothlorien elves.
This is Galadriel's theme, which will tell the story not the Only Ring in Prologue.
But not before the topic spills over to the Ring with the first title.
When the prologue ends and the minor key passes to the majorette
the story also goes from Galadriel to Bilbo when the mood changes
and the theme goes to the lighter music theme of the Shire, as Bilbo puts us on the map.
Finally, after Bilbo puts us in time, the theme of the Fellowship is full
after which her subtitle is introduced, encompassing the start of the film.
If this masterful intertwining of topics is not enough to prove to you that composer Howard Shore is a genius
everything is fine, because there is something else to say.
First, these 4 topics I mentioned are called leitmotifs.
Technique popularized by Richard Wagner
which combines music themes with specific people, events and places
to help and even improve the development of drama and plot.
To show how Shor develops his leitmotifs
I will isolate one - the theme of the Fellowship that has the most variations.
And I will focus on her development in the first film.
Before the theme of the Fellowship is fulfilled in its full heroic glory
Shore introduces it with several variations.
For the first time after the title, we hear it when Frodo and Sam leave the County on the way to Lomidol.
Shore presents us a small part of the subject of the Shire, a notice of the final version of the film's end.
Then he moves to a slight hint of the subject of the Fellowship
using only a horn and an English horn.
This is almost immediately contrasted by a more bleak variation
while Gandalf rides to Isengard to advise Saruman.
Shore adds cinemas and combines the theme with the rhythm of Gandalf's galloping horse.
In this tense variation, Saruman is betraying the betrayal.
The two themes are supported in anticipation of the eventual disintegration of the Fellowship, later in the film.
The next time we hear the subject when Frodo and the hobbits have adopted the Speedo or Aragorn as their temporary leader.
Fellowship grows, so the copper section of the orchestra also grows.
We started with a brass horn, now we hear three.
But the melody of the subject is pressed by the sound of tympani, which gives urgency.
The Fellowship Light does not appear again until Frodo is injured by the spirits of the Ring.
While Arven was in a hurry to take Frodo to Lomidol
the theme of the Nazgulls is mixed with that of the Fellowship, threatening to conquer her.
The fellowship can fall apart before even having a chance to form.
In the middle of the movie Fellowship finally gathers.
And Shor supports this with three separate variations on the theme of Fellowship
In their full orchestration and fame.
First, as Elron announces the Fellowship
and thirdly, as the Fellowship heroically sets off on its mission.
But the second is the most interdisciplinary for me.
Just before the Fellowship leaves, Shore slightly hints at the subject of the Shire
Before being conquered by the subject of the Fellowship, suggesting that the priorities of the Hobbits have shifted
and they now have to live with the consequences of this.
Ends with unique harmony in the second half of full performance.
It's like planting a seed of doubt in the group when it gathers.
We will hear another exciting full performance in Moria's mines
The only time when all the members of the Fellowship are together in action.
But 3/4 rhythm of the Fellowship is quickly swallowed by the 5/4 rhythms of the Orcs.
And from now on, after Gandalf is lost, the subject of Fellowship will appear only as fragments
to the very end of the trilogy.
For example - after the remainder of the Fellowship leaves from Lothlorien
the subject can barely collect violins and an English horn.
Shore crushes this already weak variation as soon as it begins.
Later, as they rest on the shore, the leitmotif can not "find a beach," until uncertainty and doubt slip.
These uncertain variations of the subject tell of the fellowship of the Fellowship.
First, with Boromir's death, and then with Frodo and Sam's departure.
In fact, Shore connects these two moments with a very weak but poignant variation of the theme that fades into silence.
Like the Fellow, the theme of Fellowship is built to its full fame
and then unravels while it's just a memory of his previous heroism.
Shore does this with instrumentation, tempo and harmony.
And it does for several other leitmotifs in the Trilogy
interlacing them one another.
The result is a complex network paired with history.
I think we rarely realize the importance of music in film art.
It is an invisible layer of pure emotion that drives or provokes us.
Or leads and provokes the story itself.
In The Trilogy, Howard Shore has given us the most complete and complicated study of leitmotifs in the history of cinema.
And the result is a musical arrangement that is as alive as the world created by Tolkien.
Thank you for your attention and thank Squarespace for sponsoring this video.
All of you who donate to Patreon and Squarespace help Nerdwriter keep working.
Squarespace does not interfere with content, which is unbelievable.
The product is incredible, allowing the creation of many elegant, professional-looking sites.
If you are not familiar with the problem, the service is very intuitive, you do not need to know programming to make your site.
You can get a free domain if you sign up for a year.
You can start your free trial at squarespace.com, and if you use the nerdwriter promo code, you will receive a 10% discount on the first purchase.
Thank you again.
Squarespace. You Should.